i love this final season i i feel like
may's really got her happy ending
the wedding to eve was spectacular on
every level
for you what was your favorite part
about that moment first of all um i
think just being able to show
love in like its purest form regardless
of you know whether it's hitra or
same-sex or
whatever that we got to really just show
two people for falling in love they just
happen to be two women and
that storyline for me was very special
and so i really wanted to honor it you
know and that relationship and then
introducing um
adam was fun too
that was a surprise to me i was like so
that there's adam adam and eve i know
like the full representation of like um
bro like a bro just showing up wow like
a frat dude
yeah totally there's an image actually
from the comic book that i've been
trying to get into the sheet the show
for like six years and we found the
perfect way in the final season which
was super special to me overall with the
way that maze's storyline was wrapped up
what were your
thoughts are you satisfied
i am i think you know
we had such a journey with the show
because
we went from you know network television
to streaming i think our show really got
to
kind of flex a little bit since we moved
to netflix and in specifically to my
character
i think we really got to explore the
layers of a very
multifaceted woman you know it's this
fine line of yes she is
a demon exploring her humanity and
making friendships and connections but
you can never forget that she's a demon
from hell so you're always walking that
like fine balance and she has her toes
dipped in like two worlds you know yeah
so so i'm really happy with how where
she ends up what will you miss most
about her certainly her costumes because
they were
so fabulous i think a big part of who
she is is how she presents herself so
certainly that i think the most the
thing i'll miss the most probably is
just continuing to learn from her
because i did i related to her on so
many labels and then at times i didn't
really understand her but i could never
judge that so the lessons i learned over
the course of six years you know living
in her skin
understanding
what makes someone like her so hard and
yet vulnerable at the same time um i
took a lot of that sort of um
home with me in fact i have her blade
tattooed uh
i don't know if you can see it sorry
oh my god
i like that i went to like grab you as
if i could
but i'm like okay here here we go
oh my when did you get that i got that
like last year that's hilarious guys i
did just almost full yes i got this like
2019 i think and uh i mean that's how
special she is to me so you know i love
that you did that that is amazing i feel
like maize and lucifer had quite the
rollercoaster journey especially over
the past couple of seasons how did you
feel about their relationship
in the end
oh so special that final scene with tom
it's certainly my favorite scene out of
like season six i think it's short but
it says like so much yeah and when you
look at these two characters
their journeys like moment to each other
you know um over the course of six years
like certainly with uh regards to their
parental issues and then relationship
issues and you know feelings of being
worthy of love and just finding their
place outside of hell so
being able to come full circle between
these two and so much of that scene is
what's not said it's sort of reading in
between the lines that i think that
that's so perfect for the two of them
and it was a it was a really fulfilling
scene to film
as the actress but
so sad as well like we
i we held each other for a good 10
minutes afterwards and just bowled
because you know
it was the last scene we got to do
together yeah
that really was the actual last scene
that you guys found yeah yeah and we
used we used what we were feeling that
day you know the weight of like saying
goodbye we put it all into the theme i
think maze had so much development over
the past six seasons and in a way i
don't know if you feel like this but i
feel like she actually got the happiest
and yes out of everybody did anything
surprise you about the ending
to be honest no because
for my character no i i worked really
closely with the writers uh in regards
to her journey i really just wanted to
have as much input as i
could
in regards to where she would end up and
so you know we really i really talked to
our showrunners and the writers just
making sure that you know everything
was really truthful and honored yeah so
i was happy
you